crucial moment right now in american
politics with the republican party
facing a very stark choice about its
future at the center of all this drama
is a congresswoman marjorie taylor-green
who escaped any punishment yesterday at
a closed-door gop meeting
over her very extreme views including
endorsing political violence
and anti-semitic falsehood meanwhile in
that same meeting congresswoman liz
chaney survived an effort to remove her
from gop
leadership with members supporting her
by a margin of 145 to 61.
she had faced public anger for voting to
impeach former president trump
chris van cleave is on capitol hill for
us chris good morning to you the
democratic-led house
is holding a vote to remove republican
congresswoman greene from committee
assignments today so simple terms
what's on the line here well you know
tony good morning we got a sense
last night for the divide inside the
republican party between the
establishment wing and
the trump wing and this private vote
over liz cheney gave some republicans
the opportunity to
defy president trump without having to
do so publicly
that will be a little bit different in
today's vote this is something that's
being forced by democrats and it's a
clear effort to tie republicans
to conspiracy theories like q anon
in the end republicans made no changes
the number one thing that happened at
the congress conference was unity
this despite members spending hours
debating whether to strip wyoming's liz
cheney of her leadership post
over her impeachment vote and georgia's
marjorie taylor greene of her committee
positions
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
said he unequivocally
condemned green's anti-semitic violent
and conspiracy-filled comments
but would not remove her from the
education or budget committee
she said she was wrong she has reached
out in other
ways and forms and nothing that she said
has been based upon
since she's been a member of congress
but greene has not publicly apologized
tweeting wednesday
no one was owed an apology and she would
never back down
after mccarthy declined to act democrats
announced they would
scheduling a floor vote thursday against
greene it's an unprecedented action
usually party leaders decide to remove
one of their own
in 2019 gop leadership removed iowa
republican steve king from his
committees
after he questioned when the term white
supremacist became offensive
king lost in a primary last year the
most recent member to be expelled from
congress was ohio democrat james
traficant in 2002.
he was convicted of 10 felony counts
including bribery racketeering and fraud
but that vote was about criminal action
today's vote is about politics and the
continued influence of former president
donald trump
former senator marco rubio campaign
manager terry sullivan
at the end of the day this vote is going
to be uh
you know we're going to see where
everybody stands on it they're going to
be forced to
vote up or down republican and democrat
the party is in the desert
it needs to find itself and it needs to
refine
its principles now without committee
membership
green loses the ability to influence
legislation that could impact her
district
but all of this controversy is certainly
raising her profile
she claims she's got a big supporter in
former president donald trump
and she's been aggressively fundraising
the last couple of weeks raising 175
000 yesterday in just 24 hours anthony
chris van cleave thank you chris